After my genetic test, I had a histamine issue.
You would suggest histamine scavenger, I seem to get amped up on it.
Yeah, we talked about that a couple times ago. That's why I stopped.
I know the story has histoclear and a DAO enzyme.
Will this work is good also. Another is natural clear hist.
This one has corsetum with this work.
There's a difference between layer histamine scavenger and natural clear hist.
And the difference is just in the ingredients of the products.
But the natural clear hist and the histamine scavenger have the same principle.
They're helping pull histamine out of the tissue.
Histoclear is a DAO enzyme. So the DAO enzyme is the purpose of that is to help break down histamine
in the gut. So the DAO enzyme isn't well absorbed. So it really is just working in the gut.
And so it is not working beyond really the gut.
So if you have an issue beyond the gut, you're trying to pull histamine out of the tissue.
Then you have to use clearestamine scavenger or histamine scavenger or the natural clearest.
And the reason why we have them both private labeled is because they have different ingredients
in them. And some people do really well in the histamine scavenger and the natural clear hist doesn't
really do a lot. And some people do better on the natural clear hist. So it's got to try the try
those and see the difference of those. That's really the only thing that you can do with that.
That DAO enzyme is for people who really have a lot of gut inflammation or and or their histamine
issues are more related to inflammation in the gut because of any food sensitivities because of
inflammatory bowel because of its histamines in their diet. That's the issue.
And then they would use the hista clear the DAO enzyme. So that's
their three different products. Two of them, the histamine scavenger and the natural clear hist
are working to pull histamine out of the tissue. Also, there's another one called ABP1 assist
to help pull histamine out of the tissue. There's three different products that can be good to
help pull histamine out of the tissue. And the hista clear is the DAO enzyme that really
helps break down histamine in the gut.